people think that the federal government
has any power except things that are
expressly prohibited and it's actually
the other way around tell me a little
bit about something that we don't know
about the Constitution that we should
know the first thing that left in my
mind was people think that the federal
government has any power except things
that are expressly prohibited and it's
actually the other way around the
federal government only has the power
that the Constitution expressly gives to
it
everything else is reserved to the
states or the people and if you think
about that that's a really important
distinction the federal government can
only do what the Constitution explicitly
says yes you may do this and the federal
government has grown so out of bounds
that it's you know it's doing the
opposite every day it does the opposite
yeah well it seems that that's how we're
governed now that almost everything is
through the federal government and
especially if you listen to the
Democratic candidates now that they seem
to want to do all of these things
regardless of what States wants it and
things like that how do they get away
with it I don't mean to make this even
partisan in general speaking I say both
parties do do I I don't I think it
starts with us honestly because think
about anything that's happening if you a
financial disaster hits a tornado in
Dallas yeah people hopefully in Texas a
little bit less at the Texas girl yeah
we look to the government and we look we
don't look to even to the state
government we look to the federal
government we want our governor to
declare a state emergency because then
we know there's more federal funds
there's more this there's more that I
think the mindsets of ever everybody has
changed so badly that we're enabling the
situation to continue so maybe we can
start at home by look I'm you know I'm
from Dallas I'm well I hope we all we're
pitching in we're helping our neighbors
we're hopefully looking to our state or
our city before we start looking to the
federal government I think that if we
can work on that that's a really big
problem I just outlined yeah but well
are you shocked it's sort of how little
it seems people know or care about our
founding documents I mean I talk about
them here all the time the Constitution
and the Declaration
of independents are sitting on the wall
in my control room right over there but
that so few people actually really think
about the documents that led to the
unprecedented freedom that we're living
in right now
we live in a world that has created that
we have schools that teach social
studies when they used to teach history
I mean you know we don't teach the
Federalist Papers which of course were
the in the anti-federalist papers which
were the arguments back and forth at the
time of the founding about the
Constitution and why it exists as it
does and what what they were trying to
create we just we don't do any of this
stuff in our schools anymore and then we
have adults that grow up having never
been exposed to this and and so nobody
knows literally nobody knows and I think
the founding generation if you read in
the Federalist Papers especially over
and over and over again
James Madison or Alexander Hamilton will
say the people will keep this in line
they and they talk about the people as
if we will be educated as if we will
know as if we will take all of this into
consideration when we're voting and
doing all the things that we do but once
you undermine education and once that's
gone how can you possibly keep this
structure in place anymore do you think
that was a miscalculation by the
founders that over time sort of that the
state would kind of slowly grow and then
as it grew that education would kind of
get worse and maybe they couldn't
envision all of that but that that was
their miscalculation that the people
would somehow always be engaged yes I
did they knew they assumed the people
would be engaged you read it over and
over again
they also assumed we would always be
more loyal to our States than to the
federal government which probably by the
way comes with the education when you
education you lose the loyalty to your
States because you stopped understanding
why it's so important why that's an
important part of the system of checks
and balances yeah we talked about the
executive and the judiciary and the
legislative and how they work against it
and with each other and how they check
and balance each other but also the
state and the federal government were
supposed to be checks on each other and
that doesn't mean States always handle
things correctly just like the federal
government doesn't handle things
correctly but it's all a part of the
process we assume that everybody make
mistakes we assume that the system where
there are so many competing powers going
head-to-head all the time that that will
in the end protect us because everything
will be it will be difficult to push in
think through too quickly and in the the
heat of the moment emotionally and isn't
that sort of the bizarre situation we're
in where now it's like we've had this
incredible system where the states could
tinker and figure out what they wanted
to do with taxes and education and gay
marriage and marijuana legalization and
literally every topic there is but now
we're outsourcing all of that and it's
like well now if the government does
some bad stuff it's not that you can
leave your state because the next day
it's gonna be the same you got to leave
the country right that's not good
that's not good I mean when you were
talking about that I was thinking
there's so many examples from history
where Wyoming for instance was the very
first state to let women vote they did
it in 1892 way before anybody else
because they thought it was a good idea
the reason was funny they want him Pyatt
more pioneers women to come out to join
all the men there were too many men and
they needed women but States used to
operate for themselves with their own
interest in mind and they made decisions
on all sorts of topics and we don't even
consider that anymore
so we're here we're here in California
which is probably doing most of that
wrong and we have an ever-expanding
government and we now have a you know
this progressive governor Newsom but
you're in Texas what are some of the
things that you think maybe Texas which
is still a little more Texas that Texas
might be doing right that maybe
California is doing wrong I mean I love
my state we're not perfect so I can also
list things were doing wrong sure but
all right well let's do both good Wow
well you can't buy a Tesla straight from
from the you have to go through all
these hoops because of the automobile
lobby from what I understand
mmm-hmm there are things that I think
are not great but mostly what we do is
we regulate less you know if you
couldn't use a straw use a straw if you
don't want to use a straw don't use this
truck so funny you say that because I
was telling you I was just in Dallas
this past weekend and you guys still
have plastic straws we like them and I
was in New York a couple days before
drinking out of this soggy straw and I'm
like this is horrible I know it's a bit
look there's arguments for and against
it whatever I'm not trying to diss
anybody's opinion on that but it just in
Texas I think we are probably more
likely not uniformly but more likely to
say make your own decision and we have
fewer taxes which I consider a great
thing you know there's no income tax
but we do have property taxes but you
choose to buy a house and then you pay
the property tax when you choose to buy
the house I hope that we're a little bit
more free down there just to kind of
make up our minds but I think the
founders would have liked that they
definitely would have liked that so so
right now we're seeing what I think are
major assault particularly on the First
Amendment so we'll start with that
particularly on on free speech now
people are very confused about
encroachments on free speech relative to
the government versus just sort of mob
rule that we see all the time
are you well do you agree with me that
free speech really isn't in a tenuous
state that maybe it hasn't been today
the last couple decades yeah I do
is it's yeah I think we kind of went
from a place where there were a whole
bunch of things that we were trying to
become more tolerant of and then we got
to the place where we were more tolerant
of a whole bunch of stuff and now we're
at a place we're on the other side where
now you're no longer choose even savings
that were the norm 20 or 30 years ago
it's like flipped on it it's it's it's
very weird to me and there's certain
things that I think you just you can't
say without all sorts of bad things
coming down on your head if you had to
sort of grade the way the system is kind
of functioning right now we're broken
we're broken I've been saying that for a
while and we're just we're broken I do
think we're talking with a Electoral
College little bit I think that is one
thing that will help I do think we've
been broken before and we've come out of
it we were broken in the years after the
Civil War it was a big mess then we had
multiple elections where you know the
electoral vote in the popular vote did
not match up and there were two
elections where the recorded national
popular vote winner did not win the
election there was year after year where
the electoral map looked really really
similar very closely divided the red
areas always seem to be red and the blue
areas OECD balloon which is what we're
doing now and eventually because of the
electoral college we came out of that is
my belief because if you think about it
if you're a Democrat in the South in
those years you cannot win the White
House at all period because you don't
have enough electoral votes in your safe
areas but if you are a Republican you
have the opposite problem where you have
enough in the north-northwest which is
where it generally was to win but kind
of just barely and if the Democrats make
any inroads at all
you're gonna lose so both sides over
time had to reach out to the other side
and listen and figure it out and so
that's why I I think we're there now I
do think that's what's happening but I
also have hope that this because of the
structure the system even though we're
not educated enough about it yeah that
we will come back to a better place
where we just have to figure it out
all right so before we do the full dive
on our ACT oral college which will we'll
spend the rest of the conversation
talking about because I really really
want people to understand why the
founders started this idea and why it
actually is the right idea and all that
but in terms of the system working or
not working at the moment do you think
part of it is just that the way we
operate that that the presidency the
cult of personality around the
presidency is such that people think
that it's the president's job to do
everything so they if you if you like
Trump you kind of think oh he should
just do whatever he wants an executive
actions are okay the same time when
Obama's for you probably weren't for
executive actions or right now listening
to the candidates you know the
everything that they want to do they
don't realize they're actually not the
ones that are supposed to write the laws
they're just supposed to sign the laws
do you think that that's just a cult of
personality issue that we just pick one
person almost like we yearn for a king
and like some really perverse sense or
something like that so to really get
geeky on you let's go all the way up to
17th amendment which of course changed
the way that we elect the United States
senators and it used to be that state
legislators would pick those and now of
course we have a popular election most
like anybody else which makes senators
more like the House of Representatives
which is not what they were supposed to
be they were supposed to actually
represent the state right as a state in
the sit in the Congress so that the laws
and the process and all of the stuff
that was happening in Congress would
reflect the interest not only of the
people from the house side but also the
state legislatures which are expected of
course to be an important check and
balance on the national government well
unsurprisingly when we turn the Senate
into something more like the house we we
lost a check and now it's the Congress
has just become a place to try to get
the people as much as
feel like we want you know whether it's
good for the country whether it's good
for the state or not if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlists all right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell